Hawaii's Kilauea volcano could trigger
mass evacuations as it approaches a key
power plant today emergency officials
are very concerned about lava that is
getting closer to the geothermal plant
on the Big Island they are now worried
that it could actually trigger the
release of the deadly hydrogen sulfate
gas lava has destroyed nearly 45
buildings including one near the plant
since the eruption began about three
weeks ago
mark Strassmann is in Copiah Hawaii near
a dangerous volcanic fissure mark good
morning good morning of the 22
identified fissures a half dozen remain
active and one in particular has pushed
lava onto the grounds of a neighboring
geothermal plant and boy has there been
a scramble to make that plant safe a
rogue lava flow has crept onto the
property toward the eleven wells of the
Puna geothermal venture power plant
officials say they've dust ten
pressurized wells with cold water a
process called quenching and the 11th
has been stabilized they insist for now
the public is safe the largest volume of
lava is flowing away from the plant it's
really the residual portions that are
overflowing toward
PGV sites geologists are focused on a
half dozen active fishers USGS scientist
Steve Brenly what is the biggest worry
to you as you as you're looking where we
are with this thing I think the biggest
worry for us is the current fissure
activity could actually become a little
bit larger scientists say toxic sulfur
dioxide emissions have more than doubled
since the eruptions began meanwhile lava
continues to flow into the Pacific
mixing with the ocean water and creating
its own toxic gas still the only injury
in this crisis so far happened on land
it was super painful Daryl Clinton's
lower leg was shattered on Mother's Day
hit in the shin by a lava bomb hurled
200 yards from Fisher's 17 he had
ignored orders to evacuate his home in
Leilani estates instead of straight up
it shot it in all
horizontal direction right between the
roof and the handrail of the land I
snapped my leg in half toward my ankle
and foot and my leg were a hinge most of
this lava is still flowing toward the
Pacific and away from worry spots like
more populated areas but geologists worn
this volcano's eruption still has weeks
to go with significant unpredictability
John significant indeed thanks so much
mark